good morning believe nation today's
message is clarify what you want from
life over to you David Allen I think
people need to get sit down and clarify
what experiences are you really looking
for in your life and that doesn't
necessarily mean it can include lots of
money but it can also include what do
you want to experience with that money a
sense of freedom a sense of service a
sense of providing value to the world a
sense of self confidence and self
efficacy what is it that you're after so
there's you know in my own you know
explorations and the whole personal
growth and self-awareness the own game
for years I've been involved in that
pretty seriously you know there's an
exercise that say well what do you want
I want a red Porsche great what
experience do you think that's gonna
give you freedom in a sense of fun
whatever and then the people get the red
Porsche and they're worried about
somebody going to Dennett and they you
know they can't afford the payments on
it they didn't really get the experience
they were looking for what happened they
got the they got the symbol but they
didn't get the inner experience but if
you want the experience of freedom and
fun you can have that this afternoon it
doesn't mean you shouldn't have the red
Porsche but it just means that if you
start to focus on the inner experience
what would climbing the corporate ladder
give you as an inner experience why do
you want that what's important to you
about that and it could be it could be I
want to I want to provide you know for
my family for you know for after I'm
gone so there's a sense of building
wealth or building net worth or building
assets you know for the people around
you that that care that matter to you
that's there's no right or wrong about
any of your answers to this but I think
getting clear about whether you want to
do that or whether you want to get there
because you want to be able to impact a
much larger segment of the world for
doing good or taking it over I don't
know what do you know whatever you want
but I think that's the key is being able
to externalize and start to become
objective about well what is it that
you're after
and so just crafting your own ideal
scene not only of the things you want
which is fine don't don't stop that
knife right don't feel embarrassed that
you
a red portion so there's nothing wrong
with any of that material stuff that you
might want but it's also true that it's
a real good idea to just say let me just
play that all out and then use that as a
map just to then guide you in terms of
your intuitive decision-making I don't
think you have to work at it that hard
but I think you do need to be conscious
about it and validate it in some part of
yourself I think people focus on the
wrong things just in general just in
life people focus on the wrong things
you're attached to like David said the
porch right you want the porch why do
you want the porch maybe because you
want the excitement maybe just want it
as a status symbol so many people have
these goals that I want to make X amount
of dollars or I want to go on that
vacation or I want to buy that car or
get that house because it's a status
symbol because that's the sign getting
that Porsche is a sign that I've made it
I've made it now because I got that car
and the fact that you have so much of
your self-worth tied up into objects is
ridiculous you're a valuable human being
whether you have that car or not I've
gone from living in a basement apartment
to living with my parents
to building a 5,000 square foot custom
home from scratch to living in a condo
renting buying doesn't matter where I am
doesn't matter doesn't impact my
self-worth and because somebody else
might look at me and say oh you're
living with your parents versus oh you
have this 5,000 square-foot modern
custom home their impact their thoughts
on me has nothing to do with how I think
about myself and the value that I add to
myself and I think that's an important
distinction because a lot of the things
that you're doing in life in your
business and in life are just trying to
impress other people because the fact
that they think highly of you now makes
you feel better about yourself stop
caring so much about what other people
think about you there's a great line I
think from Quincy Jones who said not one
ounce of my self-worth comes from what
you think about me and I think it's
incredibly powerful if you can really
embrace that and let that go and stop
getting things and stop chasing dreams
and goals because you're worried about
or you're trying to impress somebody
else you know I look at some of the
goals that I have you know I want to
have a million subscribers on this
channel right I want to reach a billion
entrepreneurs the goals themselves don't
matter
much more important than how many
subscribers I'd get is how I get my
subscribers much more important than how
much money you make is how you make your
money it makes a big difference because
yes I'd love to have a million
subscribers yeah I'd get a new I'd get a
new plaque here that I could put here
this little gold YouTube play button
that's awesome but does that mean that I
made it now does that mean that suddenly
I'm a good youtuber and before I wasn't
I love the stuff I'm making I'm really
proud of the videos that I'm making I
was proud of the videos I was making a
month ago in six months ago in 3 years
ago and five years ago I might be better
now I might have more practice I might
be turning up a little bit more now I
might feel like my impact because of the
skill and work and effort that I put in
my impact is greater now but the number
itself the vanity symbol doesn't mean
anything now I still want to have that
goal it's great to have goals I think
the goals are are important measures
that go after it's awesome but my
self-worth is not tied up to whether I
hit a million subscribers or not
and I think that's a problem for a lot
of people I think people make the wrong
decisions do the wrong things and focus
on the things are not important me
having a million subscribers is nowhere
close nowhere near as important as the
impact that I feel like I'm having on
you guys touching your life getting in
here for you that's important for me I
want you to go off and do amazing things
with your life and with your business
that's why I make these videos I hope
that something in here inspires you to
want to go off and have a positive
impact on the world
that fuels me every single day and it
doesn't matter if I have a million
subscribers or not I think just asking
yourself why why is this important to me
why is that thing that you're chasing so
important to you and at the end of the
day it's because it's to impress
somebody else or because your self-worth
is tied up into something else that's
the wrong reason to do it and you'll
never really have success doing it
because it's always gonna be something
else is that was gonna be some new
person to impress or the impressed
feeling lasts for five minutes and then
they're not impressed anymore so you got
to go off and do something else or that
status symbol that you got great great
for where you are but now it's always
gonna be somebody else who has more than
you and that's just chasing a hollow
existence we're doing meaningful work
proud of that's what you want to focus
on so I think it's super important to
understand why you're chasing the things
you are and get that clarity on your
life and when you do has a big it has a
big impact in such a direction for you
to be able to go off and do something
meaningful and powerful so the question
of the day today is are you chasing the
right things in life what are you
chasing leave it in the comments below
I'm gonna join in the discussion I also
want to give a quick shout out to Roger
Pierce from Pierce words comm Roger
bought 2 copies of my audiobook Thank
You Roger really means a lot to me so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon